it's a fool a Capcom exclusive hey this
power 98.3 minute 628 hey we got a
special edition tonight my dude Machine
Gun Kelly is in town so I got my dude in
the building with me and uh he's gonna
vent y'all what he wants to hate on
Kells what you hate no brother who like
him you know what I hate what do you
hate I hate when I turn on the TV and I
see people called Justin Bieber a rock
star Justin zebra letting this
generation think what is so lame be
don't use that word that's a word that
we use on on oh geez like Tommy Lee on
Axl Rose or Nikki Sixx or real on people
who really genuinely are wrong about
their life and also to be a rock star
you kind of have to write your own music
and Bieber is not negative there it is
my man Machine Gun Kelly is hating on
Justin Bieber being hard rock star all
right
tell somebody to get his manager your
black bandanna you look too much like
get him off that lien you should want to
leave this tower 98.3 your 6:28 Machine
Gun Kelly a studio